[Music]  well once again we want to make sure  that you know that early voting starts  tomorrow and it runs through june 10th  and of course there are some changes  this time around so this is the very  first year that nevada voters will be  able to get a mail ballot now here are  some things to keep in mind of course  make sure that you sign the outside of  your envelope very important  specifically for you before mailing your  ballot back or maybe if you're going to  be dropping it in the dropbox also do  not put your ballot in someone else's  folder in someone else's voters return  envelope make sure that you send it by  election day at the very latest and of  course also we want to make sure that  you have this  very important resource eightnewsnow.com  all the information is there as well as  how you at home can check your status of  your ballot vanessa